la reprise de la guerre des villes entre
l'iran et l'irak et son cortège de
victimes parmi les civils bagdad a été
une nouvelle fois la cible aujourd'hui
des missiles iraniens particulièrement
meurtriers cette fois le raid a visé une
école de la capitale irakienne tuant 32
personnes dont 29 enfants michel
mompontet c'est ce matin à 7h55 soit
cinq minutes avant le début des cours de
cette école de bagdad qu'un missile
iranien sol sol s'est écrasé dans la
cour de récréation
le bilan est très lourd sous les
décombres 32 morts dont 29 petits élèves
et plus de 280 blessés
c'est le quatrième missiles iraniens qui
vient frapper bagdad en moins de huit
jours
depuis le 5 octobre la guerre des villes
entre l'iran et l'irak semble reparti
aussi violemment aussi aveuglément qu'à
son début
il y a trois ans cette guerre des villes
véritables baromètres les affrontements
et tensions actuelles du golfe semble
désormais ponctuer chaque attaque contre
les pétroliers la dernière hier par
l'aviation irakienne
mais même si bagdad affirmé aujourd'hui
détenir un missile sol sol de
fabrication irakienne est capable par sa
portée de toucher téhéran la capitale
iranienne n'a jamais eu à subir de tels
désastres